♪ (GENTLE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
TANYA MCQUOID: Whenever I stay
at a White Lotus,
I always have a memorable time.
Always.
Welcome to the White Lotus
in Sicily.
La dolce vita.
You guys are here to learn
about your Sicilian roots?
Sounds like a fun boys' trip.
Wasn't supposed to be
a boys' trip.
We're on a family vacation
right now
and it's just the three of us
'cause all the women
in our family hate you.
Please, can we just drop it?
CAMERON BABCOCK:
Now that he's loaded,
do you think he regrets marrying
such a dud?
What is going on with you?
There's a reason they invited
us here.
It's like you sold your company,
you got rich,
and now he's your best friend?
Are these the kind of people
we're going to be hanging out
with now?
Did you vote, babe? Be honest.
I did. Didn't I?
Doesn't matter.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Flirting is one of the pleasures
of life.
You're 80 years old.
BERT DI GRASSO: But the women
I desire remain young.
You can relate to that.
I just wanted to inform you
that my good friends here,
they're gonna be visiting me
this week.
Coming and going.
They come...
and go.
-See you later.
-SPEAKER: Bye.
I see.
You bring your assistant
to a vacation with your husband.
It's not like she's gonna be
in our bed and stuff.
I don't know what's going on
with Greg.
But I think it's bullshit.
I think he's having an affair.
I've seen a lot of guys
who, like, make all this money
and they just
start acting different.
You guys party?
-Lady Molly.
-CAMERON: (CHUCKLING)
My God, are you kidding?
-Let's fun! (GIGGLES)
-"Let's fun."
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
A man does what he has to do,
but you keep it tight.
If you're sloppy, it's like
you're rubbing her face in it.
What happened last night?
It's just been a series
of very bad decisions.
You've had very bad luck.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
QUENTIN: The best thing
about luck is...
it can always change.
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
SPEAKER 2:
Italy's just so romantic.
You're gonna die.
I'm gonna have to drag you
outta here.
♪ (MUSIC RESUMES, CONCLUDES) ♪